a pumpkin orange sweaty and slurring
Donald Trump is now giving marching
orders to Republicans who have taken
control of the House of Representatives
I don't know that they're listening to
Trump I don't know that they care what
Trump says anymore some of them anyway
but Donald Trump put out a video two and
a half minutes long telling Republicans
exactly what he expects them to do we
have not digitally altered this video
this is really Trump's physical
appearance this is really Trump's voice
notice also the jump Cuts done terribly
Trump really struggles to record this
drivel so they often have to take it a
sentence at a time usually when you do
this you do the jump cut from a
different angle so it's not obvious that
it's stitched together
um with with Trump it's just a disaster
everything about this video is a
disaster let's take a look the new house
committee on the weaponization of the
federal government is a rare chance to
expose the breathtaking corruption
of the security State the media and the
Washington swamp is Trump okay I mean
this level of sweating I almost wonder
whether the orange fake tan is to cover
something else going on his eyes are
almost completely swollen shut like
slits I mean it it it it it does not
look good
here are just a few of the questions the
committee hopefully will be asking who
in the Mueller team was in charge of
leaking okay so this was a smart jump
cut they actually went to the side
secret information and fake news stories
to dishonest journalists of which are
many to perpetrate the Russia hoax and
that's what it was turned out it was a
total hoax it was all
misinformation it was all a horrible
thing that was given to the people of
our country
illegally by a fake press at a corrupt
press and understand that there was
nothing illegal about the Russia probe
Nothing by corrupt politicians today the
fake steel dossier was first published
because they knew it was fake and they
knew that sometimes there'd be a guy
like Trump that wants to go after them
have any fake news journalists been paid
or compensated by U.S government
agencies directly or indirectly for
their role in spreading domestic
disinformation like the FBI did with
Twitter who orchestrated the FBI's
repeated operations to interfere in
domestic politics I genuinely don't
think Trump even understands the words
he's reading off the prompter he seems
lost in the prompter and completely
disconnected from the meaning of what
he's saying 10 weeks of multiple U.S
election Seasons right and specifically
at most importantly
in the presidential election of 2020
what the FBI did was suppress anything
bad about Biden
and go all out
put it all out there if it was anything
at all bad about Trump and if there
wasn't anything bad we'll make it up
now none of this is true I I know you
know that and of course he doesn't cite
any examples that was as a rigged
election just by itself for all the
federal agents and is that jump cut was
so bad they cut off one of Trump's words
who's editing these things performance
and pressing the crowd toward the
capital
on January 6 and who is raps tell me
about raps where does he come from I
think we know this is Trump feeding this
conspiracy theory that Ray Epps a man
who was videotaped in DC the day before
the January 6 riots the the idea that
some right-wingers have is that he was
actually an FBI either informant or
actual agent of course there was no
evidence of that
whatsoever and there's just no evidence
of that whatsoever period
in addition the committee needs to do a
full review of Pfizer warrants
we should also get a full report and
they're an audio glitch that was in the
video just so you know it's just a
disastrous video any domestic
surveillance of Maga supporters
that has taken place under Biden
or Obama and the radical left season
is very in fact deep-seated
it's a deep-seated deep State the
greatest threat American freedom in
Generations has seen and their collusion
with the fake news media is absolutely
atrocious
this committee is a vital chance to
bring it all to life this is arguably
the worst that Trump has sounded forget
about how he looks
struggling to put together these words
and of course he is pretending as though
he is now going to direct these
ridiculous committees that Republicans
are putting together the weaponization
committee their covid committee which is
not really a coveted committee it's sort
of like a get fouchy committee Trump
believes he is now going to direct
Republicans in their uh investigations
if that's what you're going to call them
maybe he's right I am not going to
assume until we see is Trump still in
control of the Republican party or is he
not his endorsement record in contested
races in November was not particularly
good as you know
um and so we'll see whether Republicans
are going to listen to Trump or not but
he really doesn't look good and uh the
rallies I guess are starting soon this
weekend there's going to be it's called
an event I guess it's not really a rally
I don't know what it is in South
Carolina I told you Trump was struggling
to find state legislators willing to go
up on stage and support him uh our
correspondent Luke Beasley is going to
be there interviewing people and
hopefully some of the questions Luke
asks will be about like do you still
think that that this is the guy that's
good for your party uh but real it's
just Amateur hour in every way the
reading the filming the audio it's
completely Bonkers let's now go from
talking about the guy who wants to be
president to the gal who wants to be his
vice president
email Services by big tech companies
scan every single email you send and
receive emails from your doctor your
spouse that's why you get those creepy
ads a few minutes later and other
companies collect your data every time
you open an email from them it's a huge
mess all of this information gets sold
around they can piece together where
you've been who you know what you like
and it's out there forever that's why I
recommend start mail start mail never
collect data from your emails it blocks
The Trackers embedded in the emails that
you receive start mail encrypts every
email you send protecting it from prying
eyes even the government start mail
never shows you ads and unlike other
services when you delete an email it's
gone forever and I love this part you
can create unlimited email aliases so
you don't have to give companies your
real email address which can really cut
down on spam you can seamlessly migrate
your emails and contacts from Gmail
Outlook Yahoo and others it's really
easy start taking your privacy seriously
by signing up for start mail you'll get
50 off your first year subscription go
to startmail.com Pacman the link is down
below